لقد قدمت أداءً جيدًا حقًا ضد هولندا
ولكنك لم تفز
اليوم ، فأنت تبلي بلاءً حسنًا وأنت
تفوز بما تقوله عن هذه المباراة
جيدًا أعتقد أن هذه المباراة تم إعدادها
بشكل مثالي ، لقد حصلنا على التشكيل الصحيح
وكان اللاعبون يتمتعون بدوافع جيدة حقًا.
والأجواء كانت رائعة ، جاء الكثير
من السنغال إلى الشتات
وكان جميع أسلافنا من
إفريقيا على أرض الملعب اليوم ، لذا
سيواصل اللاعبون ذلك بالفعل وفزنا ونحن
سعداء حقًا ونصرخ أيضًا
للفرق القطرية  لقد كانوا جيدين حقًا ،
ما الذي يعنيه
هذا اليوم بالنسبة للسنغاليين ، فهذا يعني
الكثير لأنه يعني الكثير لأن الجميع كان
متوترًا وعصبيًا نوعًا ما بعد
مباراة هولندا وبعد هذا الفوز
أعتقد أن الجميع قد عاد
ليكونوا متحمسين و  أعتقد أنها ستجلب
طريقة جديدة من نوع الإثارة
للفريق ، اللاعب والجميع ،
وآمل أن تتمكنوا من الفوز بالمباراة القادمة
ضد الإكوادور ،
ما رأيكم يا رفاق
في غياب ساديو ماني يوم الثلاثاء؟
بطولته ، كم كان مؤثرًا ، أعتقد أن ساديو
ماني كان غائبًا حقًا عن
مباراة هولندا وأعتقد اليوم
أنني اختلقتها ، لكن ساديو ماني هو لاعب رئيسي
في الفريق ، ونحن نفتقده حقًا ،
ونحن ندعو له أن يستعيد لياقته قريبًا.
غرب إفريقيا وأفريقيا بأكملها
نصلي من أجلك أشعر أن
ساعة الصلاة قادمة إليك وسنكون
بخير قريبًا وستكون هناك
فتيات وتهنئة شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] أجنبية
شكرًا لك  شكرا لكم اه شكرا كاتا
كاتا جميلة
انها ماشاء الله جيدة
شكرا يا رفاق شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]